[Music]
it's up guest mkbhd here so I was on
Twitter earlier just scrolling you know
normal Twitter stuff and I saw a tweet
from fellow youtuber super staff that
really hit home you know in this world
that we're in it said you say something
positive about a product and those
comments asking how much do they pay you
but if you say something negative about
that product they're asking how much did
their competitor pay you can't win and
so I chimed in also if you say nothing
about a product they're asking you well
why you ignoring it why you wait you
hate them and it's obviously all you
know poking fun but there is a hint of
truth in it when you actually go through
the youtube comment section which maybe
you should never go through but when you
go through them on tech videos you see
that kind of stuff all the time so let's
talk me and you
the commenters let's talk about the
actual ethics of being a tech reviewer
on YouTube so the the backdrop to all
this is this isn't the early days of
YouTube anymore and there's always been
you know these much longer more
well-established industries that can be
a part of you can work for The Times and
the journals and the posts on the CNET's
of the world but now there's a newer way
to do it and that's why being an
independent individual publisher on any
number of platforms and one of the
biggest happens to be by making videos
here on YouTube actually remember not
very long ago when it just wasn't like
this at all you know when actually when
I was in college studying business and
marketing this wasn't even a real career
path there was maybe like a single-digit
number of humans on planet earth doing
this for a living so it was kind of like
the Wild West write your own rules do
what you want to do but it's been slowly
gaining respect and traction ever since
then but because it's independent you
kind of just are writing your own rules
doing what you think is right hopefully
well most of the time so in the United
States we do have what's called the FTC
the Federal Trade Commission and they do
have rules and structures and even a
written set of guidelines for social
media marketing there's a whole PDF on
their site you can read if you want to
right now I'll link it below and most of
the
points are about disclosure so that
customers know when they're being
advertised to can't be shady or tricky
about it customers deserve to know when
they're looking at paid advertising and
that's a that's a good cause right
that's a cause I can get behind but I
think a lot of us have noticed that
these aren't really easily
or well enforced and a lot of these
companies if they didn't have to ever
disclose that they were advertising they
never would because they know nobody
really likes advertising and they would
all try to deceive you into thinking
that you're watching something organic
when it's really a paid ad now of course
that shouldn't happen but this is an
independent space and a lot of people
don't really play exactly by the rules
that the FTC is made take this one for
example here's a post from a good friend
Zach Jerry rigged everything on YouTube
post it on Instagram with proper
disclosure well done now here's a I
think clearly an ad for the same thing
from someone and be part of the Sam
campaign but no disclosure of any kind
from Shaq now I love Shaq but was that
really like are we supposed to believe
that that's not an from someone who we
used to call the big diesel are we
supposed to believe that ad for an
electric truck was really just your
words seriously it's pretty obvious not
everyone's playing by the same rules so
we're still trying to figure out how
this is supposed to be how this should
be done in 2020 and so I figured I
should just tell you how I run things
here on the mkbhd YouTube channel
transparency actually I had a very
recently mr. Mobile on the wave form
podcast again I'll link that episode
below where we talked about all this
tech YouTube ethics stuff in much
greater detail and I had him on because
we line up on a lot of this ethic stuff
he has a great ethics page but also at
the end of his videos he has this little
section in his reviews where he says
this disclosure this review was produced
following five days with a set of 20/20
pixel buds provided by Google I don't do
paid reviews though the company paid no
compensation for this coverage and also
didn't get an early look or any copy
approval rights concerning it that means
Google is seeing this for the first time
right alongside you and I was like oh
that's good that's good and I'm watching
this like me too of course but the fact
that he has to say that
I guess that means not everyone treats
it the same way not everyone does it
like that so for me for the mkbhd
channel you should know one I have never
and will never do paid reviews and two I
have never and will never give a
manufacturer an early look at a review
before it goes live every time you see a
review you're seeing it at the same time
that manufacturer is seeing it too and I
also want to be very clear about what
exactly is a review like I think that
word review gets thrown out there a
little more loosely in some places so to
me a tech review is an evaluation of a
product to figure out if you should buy
it or not so it'll have my experiences
my opinions and my recommendations and
that's what makes an mkbhd review so not
every tech video is a review a sponsored
video will also never be a review that
would be more of like a product showcase
essentially and it's funny people people
love throwing out the word review oh
there will be like a like a day one
hands-on or first impressions of
something like as soon as it comes out
and there's always a comment like hey
nice review that's not a review there's
actually a playlist specifically of all
the reviews on the channel and just for
good measure I almost always have the
word review in the title of reviews as
well so if we're ever unsure if
something is an mkbhd review or not
because it wasn't in the title and it's
not in the reviews playlist and I didn't
say it was a review in the video it's
because it's not a review another hard
line for my channel is there will never
be a product review sponsored by the
company that makes that product never
just not a good fit for me now that's
not to say that no one can or should do
this in fact there are plenty that do
here's a good example Peter McKinnon
just reviewed the canon r5 one of the
earliest and best reviews of one of the
most important new cameras and he has
canon as a channel sponsor but he's
obviously super upfront about that in
the beginning of the video and he
doesn't let it affect his review and he
goes through the whole thing it's one of
the best videos you should watch so it
can be done well it's just for me in
tech that's a tough distinction to make
so
that's not something that I'll do on
this channel now all that being said
that doesn't mean I'll never do anything
sponsored of course I've partnered with
brands before and these are sort of a
necessary thing as I'll explain but just
business-wise you'll never hear of a
business relying entirely on like
something like Adsense revenue as as a
variable so to break it down there are
two ways that I work with companies
there are sponsored segments and
collaborations with brands so a
sponsored message it's pretty simple
you're probably familiar with it by now
we'll hear something like this video is
sponsored by or this portion of the
video is brought to you by or you can
pick it up at our channel sponsor deeper
and something like that that is a paid
for message by a hand-selected sponsor
who we to make something that I believe
in or that I think is good that will
always be disclosed aim I've actually
seen recently YouTube has decided in
like the next month or so to
automatically enable mid rolls on all
monetize videos over eight minutes and
should just like try to decide where the
mid roll should go you've seen those
like mid-roll interruptions before I
don't like that very much
I don't enable mid rolls on very many of
my own ten-minute videos so I do think
the hand-selected sponsored message that
you can integrate much more easily and
much more seamlessly is a better way of
doing that so I don't typically have mid
rolls in my videos and I would rather go
with the actual sponsored message and
then a brand collaboration is a little
bit more nebulous I'd classify it as any
time a video wouldn't be possible
without the cooperation of some company
so whether it's a dope tech video
on-camera robots where the company that
makes them invited us out to their
studio in Portland we fly out there we
play with those crazy machines for a day
or two and record it or when I got to
sit down and talk tech in apparel with
the legend Kobe Bryant thanks to
partnering with Nike on his new shoe
launch or even just a smart phone
company sending a phone to the studio
two weeks early for me to check it out
and get some daily use in to make a
launch day review these are all kind of
brand collaborations in some way to make
those videos possible but importantly
know
of them are paid but I actually think
these can usually make some of the best
videos just by enabling things that
wouldn't be possible like how else would
a nervous college kid interview Kobe
Bryant or how else would I get you know
to interview people who are behind the
scenes that making products or to get a
sneak peek in things that haven't come
out yet all this stuff usually makes
like the more fun interesting videos it
is my policy on this channel to keep
those unpaid not everybody does that and
that's fine as long as those are
disclosed but now you know my policy on
that too I have done one fully sponsored
entire video in the history of the
channel you probably remember the Buick
video I had never done a fully sponsored
video before in over eleven years and in
over a thousand videos and we learned a
lot from that experience and its pros
and cons I'm not against them actually I
just think they are typically more
difficult to execute well so to go back
to that super staff tweet at the
beginning if I ever say something
positive about a product in a video it's
because I genuinely think it's good and
if I say something bad about a product
it's because I genuinely think it's bad
I have absolutely no concern about my
relationship with a company changing
because of something I say in a review
because I plan on saying the truth every
time so if a company gets mad or doesn't
want to send review devices anymore or
or invite me to events whatever it is
because of what I said in a review
because of a truth that I spoke about
their product it actually looks worse on
them we are very fortunate as a channel
not to be in a position where we rely on
having to be first to make it worth
making a video typically which basically
means if there's a product that doesn't
get sent to the studio for an advanced
review like and this happens all the
time like there's Plex you guys asked
about I'm still trying to get my hands
on like Sony's Xperia 1 mark 2 Canon r5
like if I don't get them early I buy
them and then I review them when they
get here one thing I do want to be more
clear about is disclosing when a product
being reviewed was provided by the
company that makes it versus one that I
purchase
myself it's a pretty healthy mix on the
channel a lot of people don't realize
that but I used to put that in the
description of every review and I'd stop
for a while I plan on bringing that back
so you can accuse me of being biased
sure you know all of us reviewers we
have our preferences and basically you
can calibrate yourself to all of our
preferences but what you can't accuse me
of as being paid off for a positive
review because at the end of the day
whether I say a positive or a negative
thing about the product that's just me
keeping it real oh and for the whole
like if you say nothing then people ask
well why do you hate them so much and
not talk about them that whole thing and
it's like we have to pick and choose our
battles over here man like I wish I
could make a whole new video every
single day because sometimes there is
that much to talk about but it's a small
team here actually during the pandemic
it's a kind of the solo mission but it's
a small team it's we're based in the US
so typically I'm able to get my hands on
products that are available here and
then generally I'm just hopping around
focusing on things that I'm enthusiastic
about that's what makes the videos fun
that's what makes them interesting and I
think if I try to review everything that
would kind of take away from that
so can you trust mkbhd can you trust me
I hope so but I believe it is an
important question to ask because you at
the end of the day as a viewer shouldn't
get all of your tech advice from one
person I mean think about it it's a
purchase decision should you should
experiment with other opinions and
there's a variety of us out there all of
which have different preferences and
different ethics stances so as a viewer
or that commenter on YouTube you should
be able to pick and choose and the
reason I'm telling you all this is
because I think it's important for you
to know as a viewer and I work for you
at the end of the day I think the tweets
and comments and stuff like from the
beginning of the video generally just
come from a misunderstanding or a lack
of understanding because this is so new
and it has been the Wild West for so
long so hopefully this public facing
statement the series of statements can
help you understand that better and help
build that trust more so now you know
how we run things here but hey if you
still have questions because at the end
of the day this is just me
answering what I think you should know
but if you have other questions hit me
up in the comment section below
ask me anything or I'm also gonna be
doing an AMA on reddit starting today
I think it's 8 p.m. Eastern I'll leave a
link below again ask me anything
it's an open book we can talk about it
and hopefully this lets you trust me a
little more either way that's been it a
little different video but thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace